I love collaborating with other artists
especially when it's outside of my genre
because it teaches me so much about
someone else's view on something and
their view of the business it's always
been one of my favorite things like Ray
Charles and Willie Nelson you would see
these really kind of you know unlikely
collaborations and duets and they're
just magical
and then obviously I love collaborations
because I'm in the band with high women
right which is it one giant
collaboration and I love being a solo
artist and that voice but I love sharing
the stage with someone as well some of
my favorite moments of my career have
been honoring or singing with someone
that I really respect
Dolly Parton yeah Dolly's up there when
I got to do the Elton John concert
tribute thing singing to him and Bernie
Taupin when I sang my first Grammys with
Alicia Keys I've gotten really lucky and
performing with some of my heroes dolly
will always be my number one though is
there an art to working with another
artist you have to give up some part of
yourself I assume I mean I don't think
you give up a part of yourself but and
everyone is different
I think I'm very much a a team player
it's about the the good of the song so
I've been lucky that the people I've
duetted with and collaborated with over
the years have all been very
professional and respectful and really
taking turns and not like steamrolling
the whole song doing a song with Zedd
was something that I had never done
before and I don't even think he had any
clue who I was even though by that point
I had like one my first Grammy and was
sort of becoming known in the country
world it's they're two completely
different universes the the EDM pop
world and country especially at the time
now over the years there's been a little
bit more overlap but at the time that
was one of the kind of first it opened
my
music up to the entire world after that
because everyone had heard the middle
and for those who don't listen to
country music they're like who's this
singing on it
who's Maren Morris so I just thought it
was an amazing opportunity not only for
you know myself but also people that
don't listen to country music every day
oh sure
how did that happen the collaboration on
the phones I met hozier at Bonnaroo last
year very briefly we have I have a
friend who lives in Nashville who
actually was singing backup for him and
I think she texted me one night and she
said that they were all on the bus and
they were in Europe after a show and he
was humming the bones and I was like
first of all I love hosers music and
he's a brilliant songwriter brilliant
guitar player so I was like that's so
you know I like fangirled and then he
and I are actually both on Columbia we
just kind of naturally came to the idea
that hey like if we do an alternate
version I would love to have you sing on
this like whatever you'd want to add to
it so it just felt like a really natural
way for two artists that respect each
other to come together on a song and he
just added so much beauty to it it's got
a pretty amazing voice he really does
it's like an angel if you could sing
with anybody else who was it thing I
don't know if I'd emotionally have been
able to get through it but I would have
loved to sing with Aretha I'm sure
everyone would but that honestly is that
would be an otherworldly experience to
get to do but her like maybe like Tammy
Wynette or something he's so cool